>> Like, this was so embarrassing. This whole thing was
so embarrassing. >> He loves China in a way that makes
him completely incapable of evaluating anything with regards
to China. And you cannot take him seriously on any commentary
he makes about China. Watch it, buddy. You're right on the line.
Watch it, buddy. You're right on the line. You're on thin ice,
right? You're on thin ice, buster. [music]
Wait, wait. Are you saying Hassan doesn't want to kill children?
[music] Wait, did you just say Hassan might not want to murder
babies? Excuse me. Did you just say that Hassan doesn't want
to kill kids?
[laughter] Your channel's going to be done, sir. You're Nobody's
going to listen to you anymore. Nobody's going to listen to you
anymore.
Oh, okay. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. All right, man. Apparently,
Hutch is watching. We're watching something special here. Okay.
We're watching Hassan's reaction to himself at WebSummit through
the eyes of Hutch.
All right. And then I believe Hutch goes eventually into the
Willy stuff. I just thought this would be a cool way to cover
it. Okay. I was going to cover this by itself to begin with,
but I think this would be a fun way to cover it. >> Watching
you, you rely heavily on mainstream media. You're not really
doing a lot of your own reporting. Um, so how do you see yourself
as as an extension of of mainstream media or are you something
completely different? Um, I see myself as an extension of mainstream
media because I always stress that I wouldn't be able to do what
I do if uh there wasn't real reporting happening out there from
legacy publishers and legacy media in general. So I think it's
more so a symbiotic relationship. Now, of course, there are a
lot of independent content creators out there who are much more
antagonistic, I think, towards mainstream media and and make
a brand out of uh constantly opposing mainstream resources and
mainstream. >> What? What?
>> Why? Wait, where is he? >> Is this him being strategic
because he wants to have access to the channels that exist on
mainstream media? That's what it feels like. >> Oh, does
Hutch feel like Hassan's super antagonistic mainstream? He's
obviously very antagonist.
>> I don't understand
if
those channels open so he can go on those platforms,
>> News. But >> so I think I could see maybe where
Hutch is talking about this like in that way. But I'm guessing
Assan considers, you know, Al Jazzer, things like that as mainstream
media as well. People who pay reporters who have like a journalistic
ethic,
right? So, I I think probably,
you know, Hutch would look at Hassan's view on CBS and go like,
"Yeah, Hassan's very antagonistic to mainstream media, right?"
But
despite that, I'd say there's other mainstream outlets that Hassan
would respect and care about and consider mainstream in some
way or another. But um although I do engage in a healthy amount
of media criticism
um I always stress the importance that these outlets need to
exist otherwise I would have no idea what's going on around the
world. >> So you know we're here to discuss truth uh and
the search for truth in uh media coverage. Um you know that for
me relies on getting the facts right. It's a reason why independent
journalism is is is nowhere close to uh like mainstream media
in terms of reliability.
There's no accountability. You can be you can be so like if you're
in mainstream media [clears throat] for the most part there are
editorial standards. And so if you get a story except on the
chorus story on the chorus story there were no editorial standards.
Actually,
where where was any of this belief on the chorus story? Hutch,
where was that?
>> Embarrassingly wrong. You can get fired. You can um
you know, basically
like up your career. >> It's crazy that he's giving all
of the talking points for why we were like pretty into the chorus
article and why we liked the chorus article and why we thought
it was important and he's giving them all just outside of that
environment. When he was in that environment talking about the
chorus article, he didn't know anything. He was lost
sometimes irrevocably
up your career. Now the standards I would say are a little bit
looser in modern times used to be a little bit more strict but
there are still standards. People generally do care about their
reputations in mainstream media enough to care about like um
and I mean actual journalists not opinion
heads like talking heads not like Hannity or Jesse Waters or
whatever. I'm talking about like the people that are actually
doing journalism. Those people do for the most part do care about
making sure that the information that they report is accurate,
has passed editorial muster. Um,
people like Hassan [__] and people like Tim P and
people like Kyle Kolinski, it's actually an
people like me, people like me,
right? You got to include yourself in there. >> Opposite
incentive structure for them. They are incentivized, financially
incentivized
to serve their audience red meat. They are incentivized
to tell their audience whatever they want to hear and confirm.
>> Yes. So, you always have to add yourself to this, right?
Getting yelled at by his wife. [snorts] Okay. >> Uh to
confirm their audience's priors
to play into their cognitive bias. Uh this the symbiotic kind
of audience cap. Imagine having incentives like that. I mean,
everyone has incentives like that, right? Every content creator
has incentives like that. Um,
yeah. Just how you do it. >> It's weird. It's weird when
people leave out that part when they leave out the part about
me. Like I think it's incumbent on you to say me. I'm supposed
to tell you if you guys are all arguing with me, I'm incentivized
to just tell you you're correct. >> Between independent
journalists like Hassan [__] and [__]
Tim P and their audience. So like Hassan is re rewarded very
lucratively
for telling his audience what they want to hear
there. He doesn't have an editor. There's no consequences if
he gets something wrong. His audience don't hold him accountable.
And the ones that do get purged. If you're in his chat saying
respectfully, you could even be so nice about it. Respectfully,
you got the facts wrong on this du. There's a nonzero chance
that you're going to get banned in that chat. like somewhat
>> Uh oh, wait. What am I thinking about? The kilo the
kilo thing where basically Kilo was asking like, "Hey, don't
you think what's the kilo screenshot?" He was asking something
like, "Hey, don't you think you're being like a little too harsh
on this?" And literally somebody, one of the mods at him and
goes, "Watch it, buddy. You're right on the line. Watch it, buddy.
You're right on the line. You're on thin ice, right? You're on
thin ice, buster."
>> Somewhat quickly
>> in the Hutch chat. You love to see it. >> Couldn't
you say the same about you? You don't get fired up when you get
some Yes, you can. Like I Caitlyn Collins is going to be a more
reliable or better reliable more reliable source of information
than I am. Yes.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Hutch. >> You should if
she says something, you should put more stock in her that says
that thing. There are journalists at Fox News, literally. you
know, Fox News, the national syndicate, not even or the national
um Fox News, not even the local ones, they do have actual journalists
that go out in the field and do real journalism. And you should
listen to those people before you listen to me. Okay? Often times
people like myself and obviously to a greater extent people like
Assan and Temple, they're just reporting on the things that the
actual journalists went out and like ran down, you know. Um,
>> anything that I write goes through two uh editors who
review it to check, for example, whether I spell Hassan right,
but also to get the context right and so on. And then if I'm
dealing with >> there's no Fox News before me. I mean,
it's just a it's a difference between punditry and reporting,
right?
Uh, he should be doing that split. He should be explaining like
the reporting at these places is good. There's a journalistic
ethic. They will report things correctly. But if you're looking
at the punditry where they say it's like editorials, it is punditry.
It's not anything like you know it's outside of their normal
review process. You handle that differently.
>> Allegations and so on. We have an >> the YouTube
channel says bad answer shaking my head. What do you mean bad
answer shaking my head? I think it was very good. It was a somewhat
hostile. It was contentious. I wouldn't say it was a hostile
interview, but it was a contentious interview. It was definitely
>> I mean this is such a fair line of questioning though.
So far this doesn't feel hostile.
so far the journalist that is sharing the stage with champagne
socialist.
>> Well, and the funny thing is is I don't think it's hostile
even necessarily that these people think Hassan lies. I think
it's I think it's um there's going to be something here because
for better or worse uh actually I'll just say for worse
print media and mainstream journalists are getting their lunch
taken because they are held to the standard. Right? The reason
independent journalism is so lucrative right now is because there
is no standard. You can say whatever you want and nobody is holding
you accountable in any way. >> Yeah. So the same pressures
that uh legacy publishers such as Financial Times has exist for
someone like myself as well. As a matter of fact,
No, that is not true. People go to journalists for news. People
go to content creators to have their biases
I think he's going to say like if he gets something egregiously
wrong
that that affects people in his audience. I do think that's a
cope. I would say that's like a cope answer in my opinion. I
don't think I don't think being wrong really affects
Yeah. really affects content creators that much. I would disagree
on that. I think that's a bit of a cope answer to be honest.
It's a totally different set of incentives. Is he delusional?
the same pressures that uh legacy publishers such as Financial
Times
[laughter] has
>> is he delusional
>> the same pressures that uh legacy publishers such as
Financial Times has exists for someone like myself as well. As
a matter of fact, I have even >> just just the emoting
is so funny. The mudding is so funny to me. >> Level of
liability because I don't >> He's about to say because
he doesn't have like legal counsel advising him on these kinds
of things. I mean, it might be true that he's more vulnerable
to um like lawsuits, but that doesn't really I don't know if
that's the same
uh you could you could get around that by saying that in the
United States the burden is just so unbelievably high for defamation
that you know it's just like very difficult for someone even
like Hassan to be sued, right? don't have the insurance, for
example, that a uh news might have. That makes sense. >> So,
in terms of my coverage, if I get something wrong, and there
are instances where I get something wrong. We're human after
all. Um, I will apologize for it, and I'll retract the statement.
Um, and there is this constant back and forth that's always taking
place that >> Hang on. Okay, now we got to go to um Willie
Mack has done some videos.
>> Like what? How did he respond to >> I knew this
was coming up. Hold on. >> Being wrong about
>> Some Willie Mack videos.
How did he respond to being I forget how he responded that precisely.
To be fair, that's not factual reporting. That's wrong. That's
looking at factual reporting and getting your prediction wrong.
Right now, I will say that's based on his bias, right? Hassan's
anti- America bias informed him in such a way that when the US
State Department said, "Hey, Russia's like massing logistics
troops here in a way that probably isn't like indicates this
isn't fake." Hassan went, "No, you're lying. You're just trying
to rabble rouse." Right? So, he was wrong there. I think he admitted
he was wrong. And it's funny cuz even a couple days ago, was
it was it the Venezuela thing where he said, "I don't think we're
going to do anything here, but I'm probably just setting myself
up like the Russia Ukraine thing." Like I think he admitted he
was wrong.
>> And his criminal friend catching his lies. I think it
was this one. >> I confronted Twitch. >> Can you
guys help me find the Willy Mack video? Where? Russia. >> We're
looking We're looking at Will >> I think. Hang on. >> Hutch
Hutch's
Hutch's source for his
Willy Mack show. Very cool. Most major intel, France especially,
also disagreed with US conclusions. Well, I don't know when the
US published their like rationale. I do know for a fact that
the rationale they used for making that call made like perfect
sense. It was basically like Russia was moving like refrigeration
units to the front line and basically whenever you're actually
going to invade this would be incredibly costly to move all these
refrigerated units out with packed blood and to like to actually
do first aid in the event of combat. Like that was their indicator
that they're like, "Oh, we have a good idea this is happening.
Oh, that means they're actually going to push in." There's no
reason if you're just like sort of um saber rattling to move
like logistical support in in the way they did, but I don't think
they necessarily publish all of that as they said it. >> Here's
the apology video.
Wait, do you still think that the invasion isn't going to happen?
Not trolling, just joining. I think that the peacekeeping mission
is is uh like literally that's it. That's uh overtaking Eastern
Ukrainian territories. That's absolutely invasion. That is happening.
I was wrong. I assumed that we could actually have a diplomatic
talks. I'm wrong. I I was wrong. I did not even think that Russia
would take over Eastern territories and I was wrong. I think
that if they actually if the reports are true is there's been
a lot of information that has been wrong completely wrong and
oh there's still a lot of information that the western state
department is uh is is pumping out by way of mainstream media
about like Russia is going to go and overtake Kiev and they're
going to go into is okay
he doesn't like the state department that's the bias that set
him up but he just comes out and says I
Hutch is going to keep listening I think Hutch wants to keep
listening until he says until Hassan either says something wrong
again or he tries to just I think he's just going to keep listening
hoping that Hassan will sorry he's going to hoping that Hassan
will like make up other reasons to go after the State Department,
right? He believes Russian is on a peacekeeping mission.
Wait, wait, did you not listen? Start
completely crane. But in that same apology video, he would make
more baseless claims saying Russia was never going to attack
Kiev. >> There's been a lot of information that has been
wrong, completely wrong. That by the way, this is not this is
not what the problem is that Willy's pointing out. just so you
know. >> And there's still a lot of information that the
western
>> like I believe he's saying no it wasn't a peacekeeping
mission. No, it was not. >> Is uh is is pumping out by
way of mainstream media about like Russia is going to go and
overtake. >> Oh, I didn't get enough back but
>> invasion is going to happen. Not trolling just joining.
I think that the peacekeeping mission is is uh like literally
that's it. That's over Easter. That's absolutely happening. I
was wrong. I assume >> that's absolutely an invasion. That's
absolutely happening. I was wrong. Yeah, that's what he that's
what he just said. He doesn't think it's a peacekeeping
It's pretty clear,
right? It's pretty clear in how he says that it's Russia would
take over Eastern territories. And I was wrong. I think that
if they actually if the reports are true because there's been
a lot of information that has been wrong, completely wrong. And
there's still a lot of information that the Western State Department
is uh is is pumping out by way of mainstream media about like
Russia is going to go and overtake Kiev and they're going to
go into Ukraine. But yes, this is earlier today. Vladimir Putin
said that last a couple days ago the lower parliament of Russia
recognized voted to recognize Easter and Ukrainian territories
that have some with some Russian people living in it to be independent.
is a part of Russian
this is before the full scale invasion, right? This is just their
them like activating their um their breakaway groups in
uh Daesk and Luhansk, right?
That's this would be before the actual tank columns going into
Kiev. No,
>> the areas that has a historical [__] territorial
claim to they claim there's Russians there. This is an independent
area. We voted. We decided this is an independent region. >> I
mean, he backs them in these claims, by the I mean, I don't even
Yeah, that's >> he backs Crimea. Not I don't know. Well,
I I shouldn't say I don't know what what Hassan's positions are
on um Daeskin Luhansk. He backs them in Crimea and he's got a
reasoning for it, which I disagree with personally.
But then the Crimea thing, I've I've seen a lot of people who
are very smart, no geopolitics,
who do think that Crimea genuinely is a lot of Russian speakers
who want to be a part of Russia. that Crimea is like the the
one place where that actually probably is true. And although
I don't think you give it to Russia, I don't necessarily think
I used to just think it was like total propaganda, right? That
they held referendums there and they wanted to join Russia, but
apparently that is true that it's like mostly Russian speakers.
Um, but I don't know about Luhansk uh Luhansk and Daetsk. I don't
think so. Like the Donbass, I don't think that those people really
wanted to break away at I think that was all rabble rousing by
Putin for the pretext of an invasion
>> independent region and then they say there are Russian
people there. We need to defend those Russian >> he did
with Crimea. I mean how does he feel about
>> oh Hutch is oh thank god >> I I've never seen
him I've never he'll say stuff like oh yeah the invasion is bad
and invasion you know Vladimir Putin bad. But then he'll also
say well you know those territories they seem to want to be a
part of Russia and
uh yep yep yep yep yep. I I totally agree with you guys. I disagree
that you can take that referendum as legitimate. I don't think
even if those people wanted to join the other country. I don't
think you can do that. I think a country is a country and you
can't have one region of a country vote to break away to a different
country. That's not you can't do that. Otherwise, you enable
all kinds of insane geopolitics, right? You enable exactly what
Putin was going for when he was setting up all those forces in
the donass to go and say like we're rebelling, right? That is
essentially what Putin was doing. If you accept that people can
just vote away their sovereignty or vote their sovereignty um
into the hands of another nation. Yeah. You can't do that. You
you literally
can't accept it. >> And you know there's like Crimea River
kind of a thing like oh that was like a valid you know that were
they were valid they were valid to take that um >> people
and then they will [__] push troops there to do peacekeeping
missions and it's basically just an annexation. Okay. Labar's
god damn wait what? I'm not saying that's appropriate for the
record. I'm not agreeing with that. So I don't know why people
don't understand where I'm coming from. I disagree with that.
I disagree with a Russian invasion of Ukrainian territories.
I've said this time and time again. Crimea is different, but
Eastern Ukraine, Eastern Ukrainian territory where Russians live
is entirely separate from that conversation. You can say backpail
and all you [__] on, but that's because you are a
brain dead idiot who cannot comprehend that new information comes
out that changes my analysis. Okay. Do you want to acknowledge
that Moses was gone from the ministry lines held by Ukraine forces
though goes into support claims and they will necessarily fight
forces. No, I do recognize that and that's precisely why I'm
saying that he's moving towards an act of war. Do you have thoughts
on how this might end? We'll see what happens. We'll see what
happens with we'll see what happens with the conversation uh
between you know NATO nations EU leadership. Hopefully we'll
uh hopefully that'll you know there'll be a solution to this
and there'll be like a you know another agreement that the Russian
doing right. Yes, dude. What the [__] do you want?
Of course. Of course. That's like like taking over this territory
regardless of whatever the [__] position is unacceptable.
I don't know why you like our imperialism impism. Who cares?
Yes. Impism is doing imperialism. Oh my lord, dude. I've been
Russia invading Ukraine since day one. I don't know why the [__]
you dumb asses think that I'm like pro Russian invade Ukraine.
I'm vindicating your points of view. You dumb little babies.
Okay. It would be easier if you just say outright that Putin
is bad. You know me. I famously have not. I famously have not
ever said Vladimir Putin is >> All right. And then what
did Willie Max say here? Um
and they're going to go into Ukraine. The reason why I'm saying
a lot of the information that's coming out of the State Department
is wrong or outright false is because what I'm showing you right
now is literally
uh people talking about like bombing Kiev. Okay, their take was
Ukraine is going to be invaded. Kiev is going to be invaded by
Russia. That is insane. That's psychotic. The top comment of
his apology video is I was wrong, but the West keeps lying and
saying they're going to attack Kiev. Well, that apology aged
like milk. It's not much. >> That's weird cuz in the same
clip, I think it's the same clip, he's got the same tied back
hair, same shirt, right? Am I crazy? Look at the the sweater,
the necklace. Yeah, that's like the same like the same video.
I I heard him say, "Well, actually, I don't know. Maybe they
will invade Ukraine or Kiev."
>> Garmin is wrong or outright false is going, "Well, that
apology aged like milk." It's not much of an apology if you do
the same exact thing immediately afterwards. That's my point.
But he won't let me explain that. >> Hutch just watched
something that conclusively shows that Willy Mack is cutting
context here. Will he be able to integrate that into his brain
or will he
right or will he just go Willie back said it Willie Max said
it so it's true
>> cuz he knows it'll make him look bad >> why did
you say I never apologize
if why did you just say I never apologize more you then make
more outrageous claims you apologize why did you say I never
apologize if I >> you're not he's like he's just he's just
trying a steamroll like Willie like Willie answered that question
he just repeats the question like this whole thing was so pathetic
that Willie Mack who is like a drama YouTuber and I'm not even
like trying to denigrate him for that okay Sty I will say everyone
of people like try to go insane about Hassan and Russia from
what I've seen is not that pro-Russia okay but everything they
do say about him and Russia and his like blood and soil takes
that does all apply to China okay he does love China He loves
China in a way that makes him completely incapable of evaluating
anything with regards to China. And you cannot take him seriously
on any commentary he makes about China. Okay. And Taiwan, all
of it. That stuff is crazy. All right. But people take that and
they they like try to apply the same thing to Russia. That's
not his opinions on Russia. That's you with America. No. No,
it's not the same. Because I think that Willie Mack is like pretty
um thorough. Like I I respect Okay. Okay. Hutch. All right, Hutch.
Uh yeah. Okay. That's what Willie Max work. He seems to put a
lot of effort into these videos.
>> He did not. He did not. These are I recognize all of
these. These are the greatest hits. The r/ Destiny greatest hits.
He had a He had a real treasure trove when nobody else was doing
this for a little bit. Okay. He did. He absolutely did. Those
people are good at forming narratives. They're good at coming
up with how to criticize Asan and just copying them one to one.
You know, like Turkey Tom has kiwi farms. Willie Mack had r/
Destiny. He could go there. He could get all of his his video
content from there. Just put together the clip show from there
and and present it and be correct, right? Feel correct.
Now,
it's funny cuz dude Hutch did everything to like immunize himself
against this
and he just didn't care. He just didn't care. He just went back
to the Willie Mack video was like, "No, Willie Mack's right.
I'm pretty sure Hassan's bad." Um, but he covers like YouTube
drama. He's not a politicsminded
person. He doesn't do political analysis very routinely, if ever.
Um,
and he has this he has this debate with Hassan and Hassan is
basically just trying to steamroll him the whole time. >> Meanwhile,
uh, Willie Mack like held his own in this kind of a setting.
Like the whole thing was just so embarrassing. >> I did.
And you just repeated. You just repeated after I said no, I did
apologize. You moved the goal post. You move the goal post and
you tried to act like I was just bad. >> You didn't move
the goalpost, dude. This is exactly my criticism. >> You
did. >> I didn't move the goalpost. He just never let me
finish my point. Is this what you're going to do? You're going
to talk over me when I'm giving you the
>> Yes, that's what he's going to do. >> A very straightforward
answer. I did do >> And you can tell Hassan's flustered
here, too, bro. This is like uh what did we just watch recently?
This is like Michael Nolles inviting that one guy in Soy Pill
to debate.
Probably assumed it was going to be like a pushover. And you
can see like in his demeanor
that Willie Mack was a little bit more prepared than maybe he
thought. Um >> I moved the goal post. He just never let
me finish my >> Does he Does he think that? Does he think
Willie Mack's way more prepared when Willie Mack immediately
comes in and says something that's not true? Was his reaction,
oh man, this guy's way more prepared than I thought. >> And
see like he's getting flustered here. You can see it. Like look
at it. Look at it. Yeah. >> Point. Is this what you're
going to do? You're going to talk over me when I'm giving you
the answer?
>> I'm giving you [laughter] like this was so embarrassing.
This whole thing was so embarrassing. >> God, it's so gay.
I never
I never watched this when it happened. I've never watched this
debate on a stream or by myself. I've never watched this debate
in full. Okay.
I just think it's crazy that there's like nothing happening and
Hutch is just going, "It's so embarrassing for Hassan." Dude,
even if Hassan was like right by a little bit like Willy's not
even political, Willy's like, "That means it's a total Willie
victory." [clears throat] Okay. I mean, yeah, I guess if you
massage it enough, you could probably get it there. You make
people believe that maybe. >> Straightforward answer. I
did do that. I did cover. So, you said I did apologize, but it
wasn't going to happen. And then you and I showed you apologizing
for you apologizing and then >> Dude, it's so funny cuz
I've seen Willie do this to other people now where he'll cut
stuff out of a video and he won't watch the whole video. He won't
watch the whole context or whatever. He'll just look for the
clips of like somebody saying something he disagrees with and
he won't look for anything else. And now we watch the son's apology
where he says, "Oh, maybe they will invade Kiev. I don't really
know anymore."
And it's in that apology and if only somebody else had watched
it. Now Hutch has watched it and he can't even he didn't even
it like he's like immunized himself from picking up anything
that absolves Hassan of any blame. Like anything that makes Hassan
look slightly better. It's just the Westworld issue, right? This
doesn't look like anything to me. What What did they say there?
Oh, I missed it. I didn't see it at all. >> Literally repeated
the same behavior
>> moments after your apology.
the thing that you're apologizing for, you're just repeating
that behavior moments after
>> You know, I have to confess, I first heard about you
because you got suspended on your platform on Twitch. >> Uh
and actually, you recently again got suspended. I think you've
been now seven times, I think, suspended.
>> I I want Hassan to double down in Hutch's face and say
I was correct on this last one. I've got the tally wrong.
>> Don't be a [__] >> Are you wearing
these uh temporary bands as a as a as a badge of honor? I mean,
is this become part of your >> He can't do it. I know he
won't. I say don't be a but he still makes a lot of money from
his like from his Twitch platform. He still gets a lot of his
influence from Twitch. He can't just spit in Twitch's face, right,
and say, "Oh, no. I totally wear them as badges of honor. Like,
I'm I'm totally happy to say these things." He'll say, "No, I'm
trying to, you know, follow the toss or
>> Got to be politically correct himself. >> He has
to be a little bit careful here. You know what I mean? Like he
has to be a little bit careful cuz he doesn't want to [__]
up the
good relationship that he has with like uh Twitch staff.
>> Has benefited him in just numerous and obvious ways.
>> To say I talk whatever I want uh about whatever I want
to talk about, I feel free to talk about it. And my you know
my question would be in a in a way um do you think there should
be uh red lines? I mean do you recognize that banning you occasionally
is a healthy thing? >> Um I think terms of service is a
good thing overall in order to foster more productive conversations
because in the absence of a rigorous application to terms of
service you have Twitter right. Um, having said that, the existing
terms of service can be manipulated. There's a lot of outrage
man. >> You can kind of see, right? Like there's definitely
uh there's definitely this um this is what real journalists do,
bro. That's like real journalists are not interviewing their
subjects
looking to give them like a puff piece. like real journalists,
it is their jobs to ask questions that
may come across as combative in a vacuum. This I would be surprised
if Assan really thinks this like these are questions he should
be able to answer and I don't think he should be offended at
anybody asking them cuz they aren't like they aren't in bad faith.
They're just genuinely like open-ended questions where
right I don't maybe I'm getting the wrong impression. It does
seem like he's he's trying to say, "Look, this guy didn't really
like me." >> There's like a couple things going on. Assan
is just like a dishonest person. He has demonstrated that, I
think, very clearly in the last year or two. Like, I feel like
it's he's really stepped it up. Maybe he was always this way
and I just didn't notice it as much, but I've been kind of shocked
in the last couple >> That's funny because I don't think
he meant to do it. That's why it's funny. >> Here's just
how casually this guy will lie about people that he perceives
to be enemies or in practice are enemies. He'll just say whatever
the [__] He doesn't give a [__] And I
think that he sees value in, you know, he considers himself as
someone that does agitated propaganda. And um I think in his
mind the ends justify the means. And so if he lies to let's not
forget Hassan dox doxed hutch live. I don't believe Hassan doxed
hutch.
So doxing would be maliciously showing
that is not like by that person's choice connected to who they
are. Doc, doxed. Sure, sure. Sure. I might have said that incorrect
the first time. Right. So, I think every piece of PII that Hassan
showed on his screen was already known about Hutch,
Like Hutch had had published that himself to the internet, to
the broader internet, like the state he lived in, his full name.
I don't I don't think that was him doxing Hutch.
Uh, and within that stuff, there is, I
Uh yeah, I just don't think so. Um progressive victory admitting
fault doesn't really change anything if if was rebroadcasting
a docs. I think the issue with the bad empanada video was that
it showed like a zip code for some people. I don't remember if
it was Hutch, but for some people it showed a zip code that I
think goes down to like 8 to 16 houses or something. Oh, Lingree
did post this stuff first as well. Yes,
I remember when by by the way people blame the Kiwi Farm, Destiny's
Kiwi Farm for doxing Hutch and a bunch of other people. No, that
was Lingre. That was Lingre definitely did that the first time.
Hutch felt doxed. Um, no, Hutch felt doxed when people pulled
up the like year and a half old docs from Destiny's Kiwi Farms
thread and told him, "Hey, some other people are doxing you in
Destiny's Kiwi Farms thread right now." They basically lied to
him about when and how it happened.
and he doesn't talk to anybody who will ever correct the information
for him.
He's very much very very much like Willie Mack in that exact
way.
Like he just sort of was told this by Destiny, people adjacent
to Destiny, and he just believes it cuz he's a
>> somebody who was, you know, furthering a capitalist
liberal agenda. Then to him, I think that that's morally valid.
In fact, it might even be morally necessary to lie. >> Um,
I'm not sure Hassan did that to like stress people out. I think
Hassan is just lazy to be honest with you. Like he watched the
bad empanada video that's got the political filings and he he
just did the lazy thing that was like, "Oh well this is all information
you could find easily and I don't care." And I think he's just
lazy. I don't think it was like to make them uncomfortable. He
just wanted to watch the bad empanada video. But that's still
not that doesn't make it okay. It's still criticizable that he
put information on. I think I think Dylan was the one he did
it to like in a way that Dylan could actually be mad. Um, I think
the the bad empanada video and like you could also say if you're
watching something from bad empanada, a known doxer, you should
be extra aware that there might be doc information in a video.
You should probably like I've never I think I've watched segments
of bad empanada videos, but I've never, you know, started a stream,
somebody links me a bad empanada video and gone, I'm going to
watch this without validating it. I think you should do that
if you're watching videos from actual doers, right? Like people
who do that quite often. It just seems like the like table stakes
to go and do
So again, like laziness more than anything else. Yeah. About
people. I mean, listen, I just said a little while ago we should
100% lie about Trump's uh intentions about the meme that he posted
regardless. So maybe we agree somewhat on that. Um
but the but the lengths that he's willing to go in terms of his
dishonesty is just so far beyond
um what I would be willing to compromise for. You know, >> you
know, you you you you've said you you're a Marxist. You've been
a Bernie Sanders uh supporter in in past elections. Uh at the
same time, you become a wealthy guy who bought a 2.7 million
uh house. >> More expensive now. >> More expensive
now. >> Well, good for you. You see, so Donald [laughter]
Trump has got it right. Housing prices going up is good for for
for people. No, I mean, but you know, your personality and >> um
it's good for homeowners, that's for sure. these left-wing views
and your commentary on inequality, how does that work when you're
uh a Hollywood uh house >> Well, Bernie Sanders has three
houses. Uh and that's something that people constantly bring
up uh as though this is a real point of contention. Look, I when
I didn't >> Did Bernie Sanders buy a Porsche Tay can for
how much? 200 $200,000.
He spent thousands of dollars to charter a like literal private
jet to go to Co Coachella and then wear a $3,000 outfit in Coachella.
Like there's a there's I there's obviously some validity to the
idea that socialism should not be as a movement should not be
like a poverty death cult. That's fine. But [laughter] Hassan
himself I mean like the fact God
it is
it is just like kind of funny. Okay. It's like a little bit funny.
I I can like buy that that Hassan should have put more of his
money into like actually like supporting causes he believes in.
I can buy that. I think he had enough left over to buy nice things
for himself. That's fine.
I think I I have serious judgment for anybody who's spending
$1,000 on a shirt, though. Okay. I'm sorry. I do. You're kind
of a Even if you have the extra money, you're going to spend
Unless you like get it tailored, right? If you're getting like
customtailored clothes or something, maybe. But it's that I still
don't think you would even get a shirt up to $1,000 if you're
getting it like customtailored. If you're getting anything that's
like sold by a brand to you, I feel like it's just weird, man.
Fact that he, you know, hangs out with um like Faze guys and
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's just like
I get the personal wealth arguments and it's like, yeah, there's
something there. There's like a little something there that hey,
it's really immature to like, you know, spend all this money
doing the consumer stuff and not support your your cause, but
it's like it's it's not as big a deal. You don't have to bring
it up every single time, right? It's goofy.
>> Thieves guys, which you know, say what you will about
those brands, but they're those brands are just about wealth.
Like the celebration of wealth and um
That's that's what like when I think of >> Sure. This is
maybe an argument you could construct, resi, that as you gain
wealth, um certain kinds of clothing are a symbol of status and
you display that status so that you can gain access to certain
people that you wouldn't otherwise be able to, right? I I get
it. It's like playing the game. Sure, >> like 100 Thieves
and and and FaZe as brands. Like what what do I associate with
those brands? It's just about like the celebration of wealth
and
>> and for him to be like super friendly with those guys,
you know? Um, the fact that Bernie Sanders has has three different
houses, well, that's not necessarily something that I would consider
to be like in furtherance of a hyperconsumerist culture that
we have in America, right? Like that not like he's out here like
flaunting his wealth in any kind of way and um like celebrating
the accumulation of wealth and consumerism the way that Hassan
does. Like what's his system that he calls for? Can you explain
it? I don't even know it. Well, he says he's not a communist.
He says he doesn't identify as a communist. I don't even know
if he gives himself a label. I feel like he tries to actively
avoid labels because of the whole um like hiding his power level
thing, but he's a tanky.
He's just unambiguously a tanky. He is pushing for
uh some kind of revolution and some kind of establishment of
an authoritarian leftist state.
I believe when when Hutch says this,
I What is the evidence of this by the way? I because I feel like
when I've seen Hassan take this like criticism and just say like
that's obviously not true. I don't believe in violence.
So I don't like I don't know. I've seen him say that's obviously
not true. I don't believe in violence before.
Right
now I will say I think Chaom
is the label that I've seen other people use that seems to fit
a little bit more. I don't think it's like that he wants violence.
I do think he he's basically willing to look a lot more favorably
on any
anybody who's, you know, doing communism now or has been like,
you know, a communist country. I think he's willing to look like
super favorably upon them versus, you know, the American regime
that sort of won the Cold War. >> Think we can just call
him a socialist. >> He just believes workers should have
a larger say in production. Well,
one maybe. I don't think that's all he wants. He obviously has
some alignment with, you know, communists or socialists obviously,
right? He's always said he's a revisionist Marxist. He just said
that the other day, too. He's obviously got some association.
He doesn't just want a larger share for workers. That's not all
he wants. That's like when he says, "People hate me cuz I just
want healthcare for everybody." It's like, "No, that's obviously
not why people dislike you. Stop. Stop." >> If you want
to get more specific, I think you should just call him a >> Revisionist
Marxist for sure. Okay. I don't know what he means when he says
he's not a communist because just feel like he's that that is
like the ultimate goal that he's going for, right? >> You
were meant to push back on the idea that your job is similar
to that. >> He calls himself a revisionist Marxist which
is basically just a dem a democ. But he okay he says that but
again when he had his conversation on the deprogram podcast.
So he says that but he actually lies and you can never take him
seriously.
It's like okay how do we even
how do we even how do we even at this point right? Well, yeah.
He says he's a revisionist Marxist, but actually one time when
he was hanging out with his like super communist buddies, he
said basically that he likes hiding his power level, and that
means we never have to take him seriously or or say he's telling
the truth on anything ever
>> He talked about how pushing social democratic policies,
you know, things like singlepayer healthcare, the NHS system
in the
the UK, for example.
He talked about
he talked about advocating for social democratic policies as
though it was a necessary evil in service of a more revolutionary
a more transformative
That's how he described his propaganda strategy
in no uncertain terms. I think we have to settle for pushing
for social democratic policies because
dot dot dot uh you know he perceives that it will be more difficult
to accomplish
the kind of revolutionary change that he wants on a faster timeline
and so you make this kind of bargain
to push social democratic policy. Okay, I don't want to alarm
anybody but Hutch is getting dangerously close to describing
politics.
It's almost like he's describing politics like, hey, I can't
just make the world the way I want it. So, we have to sort of
negotiate and come to a determination as a society based on who
wants what. We'll try to figure out the best path. He's sort
of describing politics, right, in a in an abstract way. Hassan
like, you know, he only doesn't want to be violent because he
wouldn't be able to get his worldview across that way. And so,
he's sort of made this bargain where he will try to accomplish
his goals democratically. Yeah. That's every single ideological
group in every Western country. Yep. Done that same thing. Yep.
>> In the meantime, that that that was his sort of stated
position just a few few years ago, like two and a half years
ago when he was on that podcast, >> of a reporter valued
only in terms of getting things right, the main area in which
new media would ideally succeed where all media fails is not
being funded by billionaires, not having editors or owners. They
tell you not to talk about certain things, having the ability
to actually say what everyone is already seeing with their eyes.
No. That's unbelievable spin.
It's bad to have editors because it's just going to lead to self-censorship.
Well, you should have editors to make sure that the stuff you're
saying is factual. Okay, I think you were meant to push back
on the idea that your job is similar to that of reporters valued
only in terms of getting things right. The main area in which
new media would ideally succeed where old media fails is in not
being funded by billionaires, not having editors or owners that
tell you not to talk about certain things, having the ability
to actually say what everyone is already seeing with their eyes.
That is a double-edged sword. It's it's why in some ways new
media succeeded, and it's definitely why it's failing now. That
can be true. Having the agility, the abil, the agility and ability
to say what you think is the truth in any given moment regardless
of other people disagreeing with you,
that can lead to you being like, you know, massively right, massively
ahead of the curve. It can also lead to you being massively wrong.
We watched Assan do I would say both, right? Ukraine Ukraine
call obviously cataclysmically wrong. Israel call ends up being
sort of validated in retrospect, right?
So it can be good, I would say.
Yeah, it's just a double-edged sword. Can be bad, can be good.
I don't like that some people get to be consistently wrong or
get to be consistently like hyperbolic or exploitative in a way
where they're they're taking people's feelings because you can,
this is the the last part is the part where having the ability
to actually say what everyone is already seeing with their eyes.
People can have a collective feeling on something. They can collectively
be seeing something, collectively believe something that is incorrect.
That's the problem. That is like humanity's greatest like downfall.
and maybe greatest strength is people can delude themselves into
believing something. Okay,
an entire company thought the zoo would be successful. You know,
you know what I'm saying? Humanity can really collectively deceive
itself. So, this doesn't The whole point of the editor is that
they're supposed to be, you know, trying to catch this stuff.
Zoom. Zoo. The Zoo. It's Microsoft. It was like the
Old joke. Okay. Old joke.
Um,
okay. Anyway, but this is this is like people think this is correct.
This is just populist, right? This is just a populist sentiment.
Hey, we all see the way things are going. And so that means it's
correct. Like the thing we see, the thing we we think we see,
that's correct. And it's like, dude, never has that been less
true than it is today, right?
I knew literally one person who ever bought a Zoom. I knew somebody
too who had a Zoom. And then I knew people who like swore it
was good after the fact. Maybe it was good. I never saw
>> You don't think that somebody can be corrupted by their
own audience or some an audience can be corrupted by the influencer?
Uh, just the same. >> I think you're meant to push back
on the idea that your job is similar to that of a reporter valued
only in terms of getting things right. The main area in which
new media would ideally succeed where old media fails is not
being funded by billionaires. Not having editors or owners that
tell you not to talk about certain things, having the ability
to actually say what everyone is already seeing with their eyes.
No, because I do see myself as complimentary to mainstream news.
And I do also recognize the real fear that this person represents.
He's just misplaced it or not even misplaced it necessarily against
me, but there is a real >> there's a real resentment in
old media against new media. But there's also an understandable
fear amongst adults that uh new media also represents this like
dangerous uh unstable information landscape and >> it's
unreliable. It's just entirely unreliable on balance especially
compared with real journalists. >> It's something that
I fear as well. Okay. It's something that I am very cognizant
about. It's something that I'm also worried about. It's something
that I spend a good deal of advocacy around speaking on. Right.
So that's the reason why I don't just like immediately dismiss
or try to deflect his criticism and and take it head on and try
to explain to him in this circumstance. >> I don't want
to I don't want to talk about that, man. I don't want to God
>> like I am somewhat different than what he thinks I am.
And maybe >> I didn't even know is that like a TTS thing
he does >> to the audience
is also coming at this issue with the same perspective because
you have to remember a lot of you by nature of being in this
chat are already completely aware of my commentary completely
aware of >> um Grand Ad Gator thank you so much for 3 months.
When were the educated on average conservative? Um okay good
for you. Let me check my work here. >> I don't super care
about this. I kind of want to get through this voted for Democrats
that has >> I'm switching over for the this part right
here. I kind of want to go to
just him back to the coverage here.
>> Um, what's his humanity? >> Um, we we'll get through
a little bit more of this and then I don't know if I'm going
to go back to the Pisco thing or if we'll watch that with like
the uh the Destiny coverage on there or what. I would like to
see that. I would like to see the criticisms as they go through.
Yeah. I don't know. I think it's rough
I might just want to watch Pisco cover it. We'll see.
>> kind of like tension and then resolving that tension
through
uh conversation, debate, consensus.
I don't know if I'm explaining this
I think I'm giving you the broadstrokes. I'm sure there's other
people smarter than me in chat that can dive more into what I'm
talking about. Um, but that was that that that way of looking
at history directly inspired Marks. Oh, yeah. >> They look
at someone like myself and go, "What is this guy's deal? What's
he about? What's he doing?" I'm speaking to those people in this
moment. >> Has a phone here. I'm sure that if you were
to go and look at the the mining operations in Congo, you would
be horrified at the conditions there. But the reality of the
matter is it's impossible to avoid that hyper exploitative structure.
So we try to do our very best to to limit the exploitation at
least in the revenue side. And the way I have said
comes comes into intro sociology through conflict theory usually
taught along
I read that comment and I'm like bro I don't know what most of
that means. means I'm not a polyai major. I know Hutch is going
to not know what any of that means. >> Things like structural
functionalism and symbolic interactionism. Well, I don't know what
that means. They are views on social interactions and relations.
Like Markx, I think like piggybacked off of Hegel, tell me if
I'm wrong, but I studied this a little bit just like on my own
about a year or two ago. Was it like a year ago? Um
Markx came along and he kind of further expanded on Hegel's dialectic
and he he viewed the way that human beings have evolved as a
species and and just sort of like how we've evolved as a
He viewed it like very specifically through the conflict between
the classes. And so it was about the relationship that people
had with
like their labor and capital.
And so that that he was like piggybacking off of Hegel in that
way. And you know some people had different ideas like some people
also piggybacked off of Hegel and they thought it was about religion.
like some some people still to this day they think that >> the
the primary thing that has really driven human development and
progress through the millennia and centuries is a religious conflict
um >> set up my business if you want to call it that is
uh the least exploitative way possible. I run a cooperative corporation.
Uh you met my my uh producer he has equal say and equal pay in
the process. Um, and uh, outside of that, the only way that uh,
you can fund what I do is through voluntary subscriptions. I
don't actually have any sort of limits on what you can and can't
see. A subscription just is you saying, I like your commentary.
I like what you're doing. I want to fund this operation. I want
to keep you going. And I always openly admit that. I'm like,
look, your subscriptions are uh, what >> you also talk
about the fact that you kind of have a permanently 30,000 people
watching that are kind of an internal board that are permanently
giving other perspectives and facts about what YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. >> NO, STOP. Come on. Stop it. You purge the non-believers.
Stop. Stop pretending like you don't do this.
>> Like when I think of Hassan's chat, I am not thinking
of a platform of, you know, open-minded, free, and fair debate.
It is just a punishing orthodoxy.
>> I did I did mention that in the >> It is a brutal
orthodoxy. And the way that they enforce it, he will go out of
his way to make public examples of
and try to humiliate people that step out of line. That's like
part of the culture of his community. I said it keeps me honest.
Having a real-time uh feedback from 30,000 people actually keeps
me honest. >> I got permab from IUK's channel for saying
the most baseline takes. Wait, what did you say? >> Um
more honest than than uh you know what other entities might uh
might do.
>> I got blocked by Hutch without ever interacting with
the guy. Kind of up >> reporter. He's an external editor.
Yes. Uh when I'm talking to older people, the way I describe
it is like uh I'm a commentator. I I never say I'm a journalist.
I don't say I'm an activist. I'm neither of those things. Even
though other people will constantly say I'm I'm both of those
things. Um I'm not I'm a political commentator. This already
exists in the professional world. This already exists in legacy
media. You know, Jake Tapper exists. Anderson Cooper exists.
There's also people doing color commentary on the side as well.
You know, Van I think he's hiding his power level here a little
bit here because I think what he wants to say is I'm a propagandist.
He says propag when he says propaganda, he means it in a non
>> dude. Why sense? like he views the mainstream media
as doing propaganda to to protect capital and the capitalist
structure and he views his own propaganda as in service of uh
the pursuit of some kind of like a Marxist revolution basically
>> exist.
Uh I did hear he banned that AC real guy. Um I don't know
>> I don't know why he banned him. I do think it's a little
weird but eh
um where was I going to go with this though? Yeah. Why did he
just pause to go like actually I don't I think Hassan was even
lying there. I actually think Hutch or sorry I actually think
Hassan like genuinely hates the mainstream media for
collaborating with billionaires like collaborating with the rich
protect >> They do propaganda to protect capital
I and the capitalist structure and he views his own propaganda
as in service of uh the pursuit of some kind of like a Marxist
revolution. basically exist and
>> against the mainstream media. I don't know, man. I'd
love to know the clips that hint at this.
It's like, how do you need to I feel like to build this narrative
for yourself, you sort of have to watch just this tiny tiny slice
of
song content, right? You have to watch this itty bitty tiny slice
of a song content that's only the worst clips you can find. And
then you could like sort of put this together after the fact
like post hawk. You just like find enough of these things you
could eventually be like he's a liar who is trying to bring about
a violent Marxist revolution. He's a Marxist Leninist. He's a
tanky. It's like yeah I think that cuts against like the broad
base of most of the things he talks about. Like I think there's
a tactic people use right when somebody streams this much. They'll
find just like the individual clips, a couple individual clips,
right?
It's I He just got He's got like such a crazy like pure
evil look at Hassan. Like Hassan is evil. He is trying to do
evil in the world. And while I disagree with Hassan's politics
a lot. I just don't see that. It's like to going to this extent
is where I I start to push back and just say, "No, I don't know
if that's true. No, I don't know if that's true. I don't know
about that one." >> And that's my job. That's the role
I see myself as as occupying. >> The reality is is that
he makes himself fabulously wealthy and in a not insignificant
way contributes to Jeff Bezos's wealth. Um
and Google's wealth
uh selling a false bill of goods like selling a revolution that
is just not coming. It's just a uh not too dissimilar from a
cult leader that tells his following or their following that
you know a comet's going to come in 10 years and take people
and go be with the alien overlords or whatever. It's pretty similar
to that. and he gets filthy rich
selling this dream that is just not going to be realized
at least for the foreseeable future. I mean if things change,
you know,
uh a fascist author authoritarian takeover or like a fascist
revolution. Sorry,
I just need one more anything else stream on Hassan [__]
Hassan's going down. Hassan is going down very soon. Hassan's
about to go down, guys. We totally killed Hassan. Okay, Hassan
is on his way down. Hassan is falling apart, guys. We got him.
Okay, let's go through this. I just found I just found some content.
Let's go. Let's go check it out cuz I actually This is one that'll
be fun cuz I think I disagree with all of you guys on this
and I do think this is like um lying on Lonerbox's name from
Hassan. Okay, so first we have this clip from O that is more
Pegasus calling out Hassan. How do you have the audacity to get
on stage and blatantly lie? He said, "If I get something wrong,
I apologize and issue retraction. I'm sorry. Is the apology here
on planet Earth? Where's the fact check? Just asking Twitch chat."
>> we literally watched this on the stream actually. So,
interesting. I'm sure somebody posted it, right?
We literally watched this happen in real time, I think.
And then it was basically that, oh, well, no, you uh you made
up too many excuses after the fact. Well, I think as long as
you apologize, you want to explain yourself after. That could
be seen as like justifying. Some people see it as justifying
your your lie or or getting something wrong, but it is boosting
Pegasus. Well, support for Assan is bad is running thin on the
ground, okay, amongst streamers for some reason. And you know,
they'll go where they have to. They'll go where they have to.
Okay, you guys are you guys are
not getting It's Pegas.
Okay, Pegasus.
Okay, thank you. Thank you. Dude, get it right. Get it right.
He literally delete. Oh, right. So then, uh, Black Black Cat
follows this up with, "He literally deleted this tweet." Smearing
Loterbox the other day with no
Project Project Esther details exploiting anti-semitism smears
to go after Israel critics in a road 1A. ICE kidnaps Makmu Khalil
Ramisa Our over Israel. DHS has domestic terrorist watch list
of 10K Americans with anti-Israel, anti-IC sentiment. You orbit
a who victimized your girlfriend.
So, this is him obviously saying Lunarbox orbits
right now. He deleted this tweet. Okay, Hassan deleted this tweet.
Where's the lie? I don't think I don't think Litterbox orbits
Destiny necessarily. I think you It depends on how you like basically
qualify that. Okay.
Um, but some people think that. Did he delete that? Yeah, he
deleted that tweet and then I think he followed up with something
else. He deleted that tweet. Now, from what I understand,
I think
this one's a little less, how how would we put this? This one's
a little better than him, you know, lying about Litterbox and
some of the circumstances going on there. It's like a little
It still is. I I don't know why Hassan deleted it. I suspect
it's because Lerbox and him have literally had a conversation
where I think Lerbox laid out what actually happened there to
him and said, "Hey, just don't lie on me. Just don't lie about
me, please. Especially in a way that like affects other people."
And
and like
I I'll do you the same courtesy. If you ever see me like lying
about you or something, you can message me and I'll correct it.
I do think Litterbox did that for him. And so I do think that
this probably felt weird. I think I also wouldn't be shocked
if just a couple people are like, "Hey man, don't bring don't
bring that into it." Okay, don't bring that into it. So, Hassan
deleted it. Somebody probably got him and said, "Hey, don't do
that." Anyway, then we have the quote tweet from this one going
back to the original thing that I believe Lonerbox messaged him
over this if I'm not mistaken, right?
I think this is what Loerbox messaged him over was this lie right
here. of Israel. Uh uh that guy Destiny that guy's girlfriend.
>> Are you kidding me with this? Are you kidding me with
this? These guys.
Wait, what is
Hold on.
When was this? And why is Wait, why is Hutch signaling about
it?
If Hutch is going to signal about that, why is he not signaling
about this guy also calling Pixie like a gold digging
every other stream?
If if Hutch is going to signal about that and say that that's
like evil to do, how is he not going after Destiny? I feel like
that's that's a little bit of you picking up Pixie and using
her as a sword when you have no concern for her whatsoever, right?
Pretty obvious. Yeah. Lonox released this video the day that
tweet was made. No foul. I am going to disagree with this. I
said this would be fun because I Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah, I knew
that. I knew that this is what it was referring to was the um
the Loader Box Drew Pavlau Destiny video. Yeah, I knew that.
I do think Yeah, I do think Loader Box does just hate Drew. So,
it's a little difficult, you know, little
I just That wasn't even the lie, by the way. Although, it is
weird to bring up because of the circumstances. That guy, he
claims to be a feminist.
Really? He say this guy claims to be a feminist is >> Okay.
All right. So, I think the weird thing that happened in this
stream and Hutch doesn't even get to it. This is actually a horrible
clip.
Wait, not surprising at all. Hassan crying about smears and repression
while platforming Noah Samson to take pot shots at litter box
is wild. Moral outrage only goes one way apparently.
Oh, well, there was I maybe spider just doesn't want to post
it. There was a potshot which is lying about the circumstances
saying that like Lottobox got cocked by Destiny or something
when I think Lottobox and Pixie met like after there was whatever
relationship between Destiny and Pixie,
That's just a lie which by the way Destiny also has put up himself.
Like Destiny has also fed into that same lie. So again, I just
think it's a little funny that these people will all use this
as a cudgel against Hassan, but did they have anything to say
when Destiny was doing it? No. No. No. They had nothing to say.
Very sad. Very tragic. Tragic display from this Hutch creature.
Okay. Tragic display. It's just stupid, man.
It's It's okay. It's It is what it is. So, I think that was the
bad thing. And I think when when they did this, I thought the
response from Loaderbox was to message Hassan and say, "Hey,
this is like a lie." And I'm guessing there was more there, like
you're probably feeding something that I don't want fed that
works against somebody who is a victim. And if you could just
not do that and if you see me lying about you in some way, feel
free to message me and I will correct it. I don't want to lie
about you. Please don't lie about me or or lie about anyone else
around me. Right?
So, I do think that it's possible that Hassan, you know, agreed
to that or something and decided to take that tweet >> Andies,
we need outreach. Get to the polls. 33% of US voters don't vote.
Thank you for this brilliant assessment. 15 months subscriber
that has been in here for 15 months. And as uh >> see what
I mean? Do you see what I mean? This is him purging the non-believer.
What did the guy even say? Was it even that bad? >> Twitch.
I think they increased the subscription uh to $7 now. Or you
don't have to do that if you don't want to. I also want >> I
just wish you, Brian Tyler Con, and others would be more than
react Andies. We need outreach. Get to the polls. 33% of US voters
don't vote. Thank you for this brilliant. >> You will never
trigger anyone,
literally anyone, the way you can trigger a champagne socialist
by telling them to take voting seriously. If you if you really
want to off leftists,
>> that would be >> in America in the year of our
Lord. >> Really, really embarrassing if Hassan didn't ban
that guy. >> 26. Tell them that voting is like really important
and that you should always vote. They get so triggered. >> I
will admit it looks like he's going to ban him. It does look
like it
>> meme to like take that universe [__] but
they hate it when you tell them. Actually, I think voting is
kind of important, you know, >> assessment 15 month subscriber
that has been in here for 15 months. And
>> I'm sure I'm sure totally sure that Hassan hates the
idea that voting is important. Okay. Yeah. Hassan Hassan must
never advocate for people to vote, right? Isn't that like Hassan's
thing? Don't vote. Didn't he do a song about how voting is is
gay? Don't vote. Don't vote. No, that was Mr. That was Mr. >> Don't
you dare. I urge everyone here to go and do door knockocking
and and phone banking, especially for a lot of these candidates
as well. >> Only for the candidates that you like. Only
for the candidates that you really like. Everybody else are on
their own. You will never He will never stump for the Democratic
candidate if it's not someone that he likes. And there's basically
zero chance of that happening. Like, I don't know, man. I think
it's fully coped to think that AOC has
I
man, it's um
God, it's it's crazy. He just does all this like weeping for
himself, right? He just does a ton of narrative weaving there.
He's like totally making up all of the coverage here. I feel
like it's it's very very only very loosely tied to like reality
in any way. Why do I go all out for you if I don't like you?
Yeah, that's obviously true. I'm just saying that, dude.
Okay. He'd only The idea that he'd only canvas for AOC. I think
he's finding a lot of people. I don't think he'd tell people
not to canvas. It's like he's going to go and try to get the
races won that do help his project. Yeah. In primaries specifically.
And then in the
I don't know like what do you want him to do? You want him to
go to like go vote for some purple state Democrat or sorry go
go canvas for some purple state Democrat who thinks abortion
should be illegal
and up the Democrat's chances of getting you know um what do
you call it a uh like some abortion law on the books
some federal abortion law enshrined
I I don't think he he doesn't want to get behind that I feel
like that's totally reasonable no there's a chance of getting
the nomination in 2028 I just I think that's full cope
full cope. I mean, have we seen the polls? It's driving the lefties
crazy. Did I react to any of these polls? I've seen so many posts.
Like, Twitter knows
populist lefties drive me insane. And so, it just feed me feeds
me like a steady stream of that.
Um, and I've seen so many posts in the last like few days.
I kind of wait. Oh, I forgot that Hutch went on Hutch went on
Lib and Learn and he was like, "No, no, no, no. I' i'd s for
Epstein if you had a D next to his name." He said something like
this and everybody else is just like, "Uh,
that was a weird comment." Even IRI, even IRI was like, "Oh,
that's a tough cell, bud. That's a tough cell, man." Even IRI
was like, "Uh, that was an absurd thing to say." Why the would
you say that? Why the would you say that, >> Uh, relapsed
a little bit with the for you tab. I shouldn't be doing >> Does
anybody have that clip? If somebody's got that clip, send that
clip right now. >> Doing that. I shouldn't click on the
for you tab. It's so stupid. I don't know why I do it. Um, but
there have been recent polls that show Kamala, you know, at like
30%,
Gavin Newsome at 20%, Pete at 10%, and then AOC like below Pete.
The idea that AOC is going to win the nomination in 2028 is probably
not going to happen, guys. Like, I I just don't I just don't
see it. I mean, first of all, I I just don't think she's ready.
I do not think she's ready. I don't think that she's strengthened
her position to the point where she can really stand out and
compete on a debate stage with, you know, with those like heavy
hitters.
Oh,
I get chat kind of gets pissed at me sometimes for saying it,
but it's it's just the truth. Like when we look at the numbers,
like the one the person right now who is best positioned to win
in 2028 is Kamla. Like that's just what the numbers show.
We're Listen, we're you would be absolutely
to run Kamla again.
Are you people insane? Dude,
I think I think the correct response
uh it's toos to say what the correct response is for anybody
advocating running comma in 2028. Okay, it's literally toos to
say what the response is there. But like for anybody doing that,
that's like precisely the blue no matter who that's going to
let make you lose to JD Vance. Okay, please for the love of God.
Holy [__] Three years. We got three years. um little
under 3 years and so there's just so much time for things to
change. But like right now
there is a very nonzero chance that Kla wins the the uh nomination
again. Well, I guess she didn't win it the first time, but she
wins the nomination in 2028. And then at that point, guys, like
I like her odds against Vance. I don't know about you guys, I
like her odds against Vance. Are you kidding me?
>> Why? Are you kidding me? She almost beat >> Wait,
wait, why? But why? Oh, I just clicked away. God damn it. Uh
I just clicked away. Please have a transcript. No, there's no
transcript. Where was I on timing? Where was I? This just went
back to his main page somehow. Oh, I had a time stamp. That's
why. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's no transcript. Well,
I'm just going to I'm just going to go for it. We can get back.
We can get back, right? We can get back there.
5:15. Okay. 5 hours 15.
A thousand times more likely than a leftist revolution in this
country. um currently and Google's wealth.
>> Oh yeah. No, >> think about it. Yeah. When you
think about it like a >> No, no, no. Not there either.
>> Literally anyone the way you can trigger
>> like way more.
We're still locked into this, right? >> Only for the candidates
that you really >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 515 was not it. 2313.
Thank you. God, I thank you.
>> Um little under three years. There's just so much time
for things to change, but like right now
there is a very nonzero chance that Kamla wins the the uh nomination
again.
Well, I guess she didn't win it the first time, but she wins
the nomination in 2028. And then at that point, guys, like I
like her odds against Vance. I don't know about you guys.
>> I like her odds against Vance. Are you kidding me? >> That's
[__] crazy, man.
>> Are you kidding me? She almost beat Donald Trump. Oh,
dude. There's no way >> in 107 days. She got really close.
The work of looking into the emails and then pick the most important
stuff is what I >> Yeah, but you're a smart person. >> Uh,
well, okay. Other smart people. >> Okay. [laughter] >> Jeffrey
Epstein. Yes or no? Hudge. >> I do. I do. I do. Yeah. But
if he had a D next to his name and he was running for [laughter]
>> Oh my god. >> I would probably vote for him. I'm
just
>> That'd be a tough one.
>> Not kidding. We're just going to let >> not a
joke. Not a joke.
>> I will say >> go for >> I think I think
the funniest thing.
>> Yeah. Uh if if a pedophile if a bro this is literally
he is lucky. He's so lucky that people don't watch all of his
content. If he's getting a log, this is like the worst quote.
That's like a certified Bana Woo moment right there. just saying
the dumbest thing that works the most like maximally against
you in your movement, right?
Yeah. Um I'm ready to sweep for any if they can win a seat for
us. Okay. You got a I can sweep for they can win the seat. Let's
go. Let's go. I need
It's Yeah, the the instincts here are crazy. I understand what
he's saying and he's probably not serious as much as he says
not a joke. Not a joke, guys. Not a joke. It is a joke. Probably.
But my god.
No, no, no, no, no. I'm I'm agreeing with you, Matt. I do think
it's a joke, but he says not a joke, by the way. Not a joke.
I'm not joking right now. He's trying to highlight how much he's
blue no matter who. But it's like, dude, just don't say like
I'll cover up. I I don't care about somebody being a Don't say
Don't say that, man. Come on. Come on, man. >> I shouldn't
say funniest thing, but the
>> like should we But if you had a D next to it, >> Jeffrey
Epstein. Yes or no? >> I do. I do. I do. Yeah, but if he
had a D next to his name and he was running for Texas [laughter]
>> Oh my god. >> I would probably vote for him. I'm
just
>> that'd be a tough one.
>> Not kidding.
>> Not a joke. Not a joke.
>> I will say >> Go for I think the funniest thing
>> I'm not Yeah. Like
if he's if he's not kidding, if he's not
>> it's rough, man. It's a rough one. It's a rough one.
That's all I can really say, dude. It's a rough one. Okay, thank
God. That's it. We are through. We are done with the Hutch stuff.
We're done with Hutch for the day. Oh my goodness. Stay. We made
it. We made it all the way to the